سالنا الناس عن الموضوع نتابع
حسب العلاقه الزوجيه ما بين الزوجين يعني
اذا كانت العلاقه ناجحه وفي تفاهم بينهم
فاكيد راح تكون مفيده واذا ما في تفاهم
ومشاكل وزي هيك بينهم راح تنعكس عليهم
سلبا طبعا صراحه يعني حسب علاقه الزوجين
اكيد واذا كان في ولاد فيعني سبحان الله
هي سنه الحياه فاكيد راح يكون اشي مفيد
لصحه القلب لصحه العقل لصحه الجسم
انا بحكي انه اه بالنسبه لالي انا لا انا
جربت اول مره نفس الوجع والثاني نفس الوجع
انا عندي التنتين متجوز اثنتين
بالنسبه ليلي مش مرتاح بنفس الموضوع انا
شايف ضد
في وجع البن وراء الحكي هلا الزواج اكيد
مفيد
بعيدا عن موضوع انه يعني لصحه القلب واللي
بيضر القلب وبيضر الجسد اللي هي الظروف
المعيشيه اللي عمالنا بنمر فيها بهاي
البلد من ظروف اقتصاديه صعبه هذا هو
الموضوع الاساسي اللي احنا المفروض انه
نركز عليه يعني اما بالنسبه للزواج اكيد
الزواج ستره وعفه يعني للشباب بس انه انت
شايفه ممكن انه نسبه كبيره في بطاله عندنا
في البلد في الشباب مش قادر يتزوج
وبالتالي هو هذا اللي عمال باثر على صحه
القلب وعلى صحه الجسد والعقل من الزواج هو
استقرار نفسي واستقرار المعنوي وبهذا
الشيء باثر على العلاقه بين الزوج اذا كان
اختيار الزوج الزوجه من نفسه او من نفسه
البيئه اللي عايش فيها فالزواج هو استقرار
اكيد استقرار فهذا استقرار يؤدي للنوع من
النجاح العاطفي استقرار وتواد وتراحم بين
الزوجين طبعا هناك بينعكس ايجابيا تكون
علاقه في العلاقه تكون حسنه بين الزوجين
اما اذا كان هناك عدم من الاستقرار بينهم
وكان هناك في مشاكل
راح ينعكس سلبا على العلاقه بين الزوجين
هلا هذا
بيعطي
اذا كان حين على الطرفين يعني بهذا بينعكس
عليه صحيا
تكون حياتهم منيحه وصحتهم منيحه